لا فرق بين نتنياهو وهتلر هذا ما قاله
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان خلال كلمه
له في مؤتمر علمي في العاصمه انقره قال
اردوغان ان نتنياهو اغنى من ادولف هتلر
لانه يتلقى كل انواع الدعم الغربي في حربه
على غزه دعونا
نستمع ما الفرق بينكم وبين هتلر هل ما
يفعله نتنياهو اقل مما فعله هتلر كلا هو
اغنى من ويحظى بدعم من الغرب وكل انواع
الدعم تاتي من الولايات المتحده ماذا
فعلوا بكل هذا الدعم قتلوا اكثر من 20 ال
من سكان
غزه تصريحات اردوغان اثارت زوبعه من
الردود الاسرائيليه نبداها ببنيامين
نتنياهو رد قائلا على هذا الموضوع من
يرتكب اباده جماعيه ضد الاكراد ويحمل
الرقم القياسي العالمي لسجن الصحفيين هو
اخر ما يمكنه او من من يمكنه الحديث عن
الاخلاق الجيش الاسرائيلي هو الجيش الاكثر
اخلاقيه في العالم ننتقل الى الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتسوغ الذي كتب ايضا
على منصه اكس وقال ادين وارفض بشده كلام
الرئيس التركي لا يوجد في تاريخ البشريه
حدث بفضاء المحرقه كلمات اردوغان مهينه
لكل يهودي عبر العالم ماذا عن بيني جانس
وهو عضو مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي الذي رد
بالقول تصريحات اردوغان تشويه صارخ للواقع
وتدنيس لذكرى المحرك ازاله تهديد حماس
تجاه مواطني اسرائيل ضروره وجوديه وواجب
اخلاقي لا مثل له من جهته رد رئيس الدائره
الاعلاميه في الرئاسه التركيه فخر الدين
على اتهامات نتنياهو عبر منصه اكس وقال
نتنياهو اخر من يتحدث عن الاخلاق اساليبه
في طرد الفلسطينيين من منازله على مدى
اربعه عقود تطورت الى قتلهم في منازلهم
ومستشفياتهم ومخيمات اللاجئين والتاريخ
سيحكم عليه بانه مجرم حرب تعليقات كثيره
على الحرب الكلاميه بين نتنياهو واردوغان
دعونا نبدا هنا
بيونس اذا يقول يونس جرائم جرائم الحرب لا
تتجزا ما ارتكبه هتلر بحق اليهود يعيشه
الان الفلسطينيون والعالم يرى ويس
لماذا تعاد الابادات لماذا يدفع
الفلسطينيون الثمن نصل ايضا الى سام يقول
سام لماذا يرفضون اي مقارنه بالمحرك هل ما
يعيشه اهالي غزه الان مختلف عن حرق اليهود
وتعذيبهم وقتلهم اوجد لي الفرق من فضلك يا
نتنياهو حتى نفهم لماذا تناى بنفسك بعيدا
عن جرائم هتلر ايضا
ساره الجرائم الفظيعه التي ارتكبها هتلر
بحق اليهود لا تبرر التنكيل بالفلسطينيين
عام 2023 بعد عقود من المحركه حلقه العنف
لا يجب ان تستمر واخيرا نصل معكم الى
ريهام تقول ريهام هنا كل هذه الجرائم تحدث
بدعم من الغرب وتمويله ما فائده الحديث ان
كانت دول العالم لا تقطع علاقتها
بالاحتلال والغرب يرسل الدعم كل يوم
اردوغان انتقد كذلك المضايقات التي يتعرض
لها اكاديميون في الغرب بسبب مواقفهم تجاه
غزه وقال العلماء الذين يقرون بوجود
النظام في غزه او الظلم عفوا في غزه
يتعرضون اليوم لضغوط وتهديدات مثل ما كان
الامر في الم المانيا النازيه قبل 80 عاما